recently tournament organizers esl and
weplay announced
one x bet as their global esports
betting partner
on paper this seems fine even boring but
in reality one ex-bet is under criminal
investigation
all three of its alleged founders are on
international
wanted lists and the website has
allegedly been fined more than a million
dollars for shady business practices
including betting on underage sporting
events
and running a porn casino
all right guys watch the video then like
the video then subscribe to the channel
and hit that notification bell so you
never miss me doing weird [ __ ] with my
hands
ever again so when esl and weplay
announced their partnership with onexbet
back in march
the idea was that esl for csgo and dota
and we play for the fgc would run
integrated ads during broadcasts and
maybe do some sponsored content in
between matches
the sort of thing that we've seen a
million times before
but once you get past the celebratory
press releases
and actually take a closer look at one x
bet
a lot of red flags start popping up fast
the russian casino embedding website was
allegedly founded by sergey karshkov
roman semiokin and dimitri kazarin in
2007
and has allegedly operated in a weird
legal gray area
for years in the uk for example one
ex-bet never technically had a legal
gambling license
which comes with a host of rules and
regulations
instead what one ex bet did was go to a
company that was above
board fsb technology in this case
and joined them under a white label
partnership
in a white label partnership is where
one company fsb
technology outsources its image likeness
and licenses to a bunch of
other companies like one xbet in order
to bring these companies under their
brand umbrella
without fully owning them and like i
said one ex-bet
hummed along for quite a while [ __ ] in
2018
they even won a sports betting
innovation award
but let's skip ahead to 2019 where
everything starts to fall apart
in february of that year fsb technology
was fined
400 000 euros roughly 482
000 usd after dutch gambling regulators
allegedly found
one x bet operating in the region
without a license
from there one expat rebounded in a big
way
they signed partnerships with premier
league soccer clubs like chelsea
liverpool and tottenham just to name a
few and to put this
into perspective this was a huge get for
1x bet
think about all of the eyeballs that
come along with
three of the biggest soccer clubs in the
world
ironically though according to a report
published in 2019 by cyber security firm
white bullet
one ex-bet was a terrible repeat
offender when it came to
advertising on illegal websites that
apparently
ripped off those same premier league
games
now you'd think that a billion dollar
soccer club would do some due diligence
on a company it's considering
partnering with if you just google 1x
bet reviews
you're met with review after review from
people saying one ex bet is essentially
a scam that wouldn't let them remove
their money from their accounts
and basically ghosted them when they
tried to contact them
five days later on august 10th the
london times published an investigation
that alleged on top of the illegal
streaming websites and not giving people
their money
that one ex-bet did the following
allowed betting on underage sporting
events
advertised a pornhub casino
and took bets on and ran a legal
cockfighting streams
okay a few things here one the
cockfighting was marketed as
battlecock which i mean great creative
vision
two the live streams were stamped with
premier league team
logos which is not a good look and three
yes naked women in gambling is very much
against the uk's gambling regulations
side note illegal cockfighting has
become a huge
problem on twitch with more channels
popping up
faster than twitch can shut them down
not long after
that the uk gambling commission slapped
1x bets award winning ass with a 720 000
fine and released a report finding them
in violation
of everything we just talked about on
top of that they also shut down
onexbet's uk website
quote a gambling commission
investigation discovered
sfb did not have sufficient oversight of
three
third-party websites or effective
anti-money laundering and social
responsibility policies and procedures
in place between january 2017 and august
of 2019.
all operators should pay close attention
to this case
as it shows that we hold all licensees
fully responsible
for third-party relationships and we
will act against any of our licensees
that do not manage
third parties appropriately these were
blatant breaches of rules we have put in
place to ensure
gambling is fair safe and crime free
end quote the report goes on to allege
that one ex-bet had basically
zero oversight when it came to stopping
customers from recklessly gambling
and it also blasted fsb technology
for not doing its due diligence before
doing business with the russia-based
company
after that report came out 14 countries
eventually banned 1x bet from operating
but through mirror websites and vpns
one x bet is still extremely easy to
access
now remember our three russian alleged
founders from before
sergei roman and dimitri well according
to a report released by russian
authorities all
three of those dudes and one ex-bet have
been under
criminal investigation since 2014
for you guessed it operating in the
country
without a gambling license which carries
a six-year prison sentence
the final report states that 1.5 billion
rubles or roughly 19.6 million usd
were seized in assets as a part of the
investigation
anyway according to the report all three
men apparently fled to cyprus
all three men are included on multiple
international wanted lists
and here's the kicker apparently sergey
korshkov
was once a cop working in a cyber crime
division
now at this point you might be thinking
okay well
they fled to cyprus they must be keeping
a low profile
nope they fled to cyprus installed a new
ceo
and kept on keeping on this is something
upper echelon gaming
highlighted in a recent video he made on
the subject
the ceo of one x bet is now miss kiriaki
kostikian a cypress resident and this by
itself is not exactly
noteworthy not at all owing to the fact
that companies wishing to dodge global
regulations by using the cypress
corporate legal system will just
partner with someone in the area to run
their company kiriaki caustician has
dozens of businesses in their name that
i could easily find
which kind of reinforces that idea and
then they continue on as normal
now a quick google search on this karaki
custikian person
who is the current ceo of 1x bet
leads you to the fact that in 2015 he
allegedly defrauded investors out of
60 million euros and then fled the
[ __ ] country alright
all of this brings us back to esl and we
play
deciding to partner with one x bank i
reached out to
everyone involved and only esl got back
to me
here's their statement quote esl is
aware of allegations made against one of
our partners for the esl pro tour and cs
go
in our esl one dota 2 competitions
we are committed to providing the best
esports experiences
to the best fans with best in-class
partners
integrity is a number one priority for
esl and as
such we are currently investigating this
matter thoroughly
to make sure we continue to live up to
that commitment end quote
now it's great that esl is investigating
the matter but you think that they would
investigate a company that they're
looking to do business with
well before they do business with them
now we've made a bunch of donations
covering the dark side of betting and
gambling in esports as well as how
esl is cracking down on match fixing in
its scenes
now while one ex-bet never got back to
me here's a statement they gave to the
london times after they published their
investigation
quote if any of these third-party
networks or partners are found to
advertise the 1x bet
brand on prohibited sites or sites which
break the law
one x bet shall investigate immediately
end quote
so will esl or replay drop 1x bet
as a partner will there be more criminal
investigations
honestly i don't know but i do have a
feeling that this
money field nightmare is not going to be
over anytime
soon from there one x bet rebounded in a
big way
signing partnerships with premier league
clock clock
clocker subs what the [ __ ] is that
very much against the uk's gambian
gambling
see i give you the easy way out because
i'm just such a
dolt that we never have to actually come
up with an n board